what's that belief nation welcome to
another YouTube hangout I am extremely
honored to have a very special guest
with me somebody who's had a huge impact
not on just on the world but on my life
as well
the one and only mr. Tony Robbins Tony
welcome aboard man thanks Evan good to
be with you now before getting started I
just want to express my gratitude to you
I know you've done so much for the
planet for humanity but also for me
personally my family this book was one
that changed not just my life but my
mom's she bought this when I was six
years old so her name is in here and it
really touched her life and was one of
the first books that I read that was
kind of an adult book and so I just want
to thank you for the impact you've had
on me personally and my family it really
meant a lot it's very critical do you
now mask what year is it it's 2018 I'm
38 oh my god well thank you I'm very
confident and give my best your mom I
will thank you we're here to talk about
your new book unshakable and and what I
found super interesting about this it
kind of feels like it's your life
strategies just applied to the financial
markets yes you open up the first page
and it says when you're truly unshakable
you have unwavering confidence even
amidst the storm which is what you've
been teaching mindset wise forever but
now apply to the financial markets is
that a fair assessment yeah I think so
except it's really about the strategies
of how to do that it's not just about
being confident what makes you
unshakable is that you understand the
immutable patterns of the marketplace
you know there are patterns just like
seasons that come about and what happens
for people since they don't you know
humanity transformed from basically
traveling constantly from place to place
we built communities once we understood
the seasons because we can know when's
the right time to plant most people do
the right thing at the wrong time and if
you do the right thing at the wrong time
you'd yet no rewards whatsoever so I in
2008 when I saw the markets just
crashing everywhere and I was working
with Paul Tudor Jones where the greater
top 10 investors in the history of the
world I've been working with him for 24
years he wore me showed me what was
coming and during that time I did
incredib
well and I was trying to tell everybody
what's happening and I was so angry
about the abuses that happened to put us
in that place I thought within you know
six months or a year stuff will be done
and two years later I saw this
documentary it was all about you know
how the meltdown happened and I realize
nothing had changed so I said you know
what I have a unique gift I have access
to some of the smartest financial minds
on earth what afraid of you 50 of the
smartest people put in the book so I did
that over five years and I did money
master the game which was 675 Dages and
so then I wrote this book because I knew
look this the longest-running bull
market we've had in our history now and
it we have a correction that's coming
and most people make stupid mistakes and
a correction affect their whole life and
I wanted to write a book that whether
you're a millennial just getting started
or you were you know a baby boomer and
think you have no time left to show you
how you can still win in any marketplace
and the unshakable 'ti comes to the fact
that understanding facts for example of
an every single year we have a
correction on average for the last
hundred years a correction is a change
that's less than 20 percent usually 10
to 20 percent the average has been 14
percent during that time now 14 percent
drop gets people's attention that you
probably would remember two years ago in
2016 in January at the worst opening in
the history of the stock market for a
january and we ended up having this
amazing year in the end people are
freaked out I remember they were
reaching out to Davos ready to how you
was there and CNBC went there and said
what do we deal you know the markets
lost two trillion dollars not down 9% he
said pick up 30 robbins book i did an
interview and i shared with him my
strategy how to make money in any season
it's called all seasons and the truth of
the matter is if you practice what he
did you're up two percent at that point
so i wanted to write a book that would
show anybody how to go where you are to
where you want to be in the shortest
time make you unshakable not based on
enthusiasm or confidence but based on
their standing the real patters one
other pattern that will throw back to
you for your questions but 80% of those
corrections 80% never become a bear
market so the market what makes money
seventy seven percent of the time that
means three out of four years you're up
it's a pretty great deal but because of
people's fear their lack of
understanding of patterns they overreact
to make dumb decisions I mean the
markets up more than
300 percent you know since since 2009 if
you got out of the worst day in 2009 you
love the day of the crash you're up 300%
today but statistics show people's 401 K
for example more than 30 percent of
people stop putting money in back then
and two-thirds the people reduce what
they put in their 401 K because of the
fear what happened 10 years ago so you
gotta understand that you've got to be
in the market place what there's a lot
of talk about control in the book what
is the one thing that you want people to
understand about control and if you have
to control they feel they don't
understand the stock market like what's
the one message you want to you want
people to take home around control I
think it's that you have to become an
owner not just a consumer you have to
take a percentage of what you earn as
simplistic as it sounds and automate it
so it comes off the top of what you earn
there's a gentleman used to work for UPS
names Theodore and theater Robinson was
this guy who never made more than
$14,000 a year and yet he retired with
seventy million dollars and gave away 35
million was a lot how did he do it he
became an owner his best friend said to
him listen to me the most important
thing in your life is we're gonna put a
12-pack so I knew it was a wealth tax
I made fourteen thousand a year goes
we're gonna make you wealthy with this
tax it's not a government taxes tax for
yourself so we're gonna take 20% of what
you earn and put in an investment
account let it build up he said I can't
afford that he goes once it's automated
you won't notice that's all he did that
made him seventy million dollars so it's
like people have to understand that no
matter how good you are in business
we all need a second business with no
employees and it takes very little time
something that once you do your homework
should take you you know 15 minutes to
an hour twice a year to rebalance
perhaps but outside of that that's what
this is this is setting up a business
that'll make you do well when I was
holding on when there's 20 24 years old
25 years old I worked with a man named
Ken Blanchard who wrote those one minute
manager books you probably remember in
heaven yeah a really great guy and he
helped them take five strokes off his
golf game and that made me god to him so
and then he would say I want to return
the favor he goes the best advice I got
growing my business was I was about to
come out with my first book and he said
a friend of mine is very wealthy said do
not put that money in your company let
the leads go to your company do not let
the
and do not spend those profits put that
a separate account that nothing ever
touches cuz your business will eat
whatever resources you have when a
growing business does that and he said
Tony I put that aside during the tough
times that's what made me say well I did
the same thing with that and my original
infomercials that alone made me a
wealthy man so when tough times came I
could withstand it so I see so many
business owners go yeah but I have
control of my business
[ __ ] you have influence of your
business yes you have more influence but
there are better entrepreneurs and you
perhaps out there as well or businesses
that get greater valuations in your
business well and so your ability to
grow you want to grow your own business
I always tell people you want to build
two businesses the business you're in in
the business you're becoming and that
you want to have the business that
you're in and becoming in an investment
business it's really simple what you set
it out and I think everybody's got to do
that if they really want to have
financial freedom because look the
marketplace changes competition changes
IBM was the head of the pack forever and
then some little kid from Microsoft
comes along and buys ms-dos for $50,000
and then leases it to them and makes
himself three billion on that little
move alone he didn't even write the
software right but you know he's doing
great and all of a sudden you know this
little company comes along a couple of
guys at Stanford called Google you know
an Apple comes along so there's always
disruption and the disruption can be
competition it could be new technology
could be a change in the culture so even
if you do everything right you could
lose I want people to have a back-up
plan this is the back-up plan I love it
and I want to dive deeper into some of
the tactics especially for entrepreneurs
but first I had a personal question
because it relates to to chaos and
control I love I love chaos I love I
love it when the markets out of control
is fly I love the stock market I love
entrepreneurship I think a lot of my
Ahrens can relate to that where I
struggle is actually internal I hate
being out of control of my body so I've
never been drunk I hate roller coasters
and never done drugs even going to your
UPW last year I had a hard time fully
100% committing because you lose control
sometimes and and I want to fix it
because I'm coming back in November to
UPW New York and I'm just I'm curious
about your perspective is on that well
yeah I look at control as a delusion
right that's the first thing it's your
desire for the illusion of control
that's pushing you what you want is
certainty you want certain you can avoid
pain you want certainty you can have
pleasure what certainly you can have a
significant and meaningful life we all
want certainty but learning ways to
control what you can control is
wonderful but you can't control most
things what you can do is influence them
it's so I look at it says don't give
myself the delusion I have control
because then I'll feel like I've lost it
at some point I never had control I've
influenced I can influence my kids I
can't control them I can influence
myself I can influence what happens to
me financially can't control it
completely and so I think if you give up
the illusion of control that loosens
things up a little bit but I think the
second thing is this the focus what you
can control which is what what you think
feel or what you do and if I focus on
the things I can control I'm going to
feel better I mean all the research
shows that human beings when they feel
out of control freak out inside and the
more they feel they're in control the
greater their self-esteem the way to
have that additional controls to say
okay when I can't control is what I do
within the seasons you can say I don't
like gravity and step off the side here
but you're gonna pay the price there are
certain things that are outside your
control but you can use gravity climb
fly a helicopter and airplane because I
understand the dynamics of how to do
that if you understand the dynamics of
the marketplace you use the marketplace
the marketplace doesn't use you and
that's why I wrote in shakable I want
people to have no more fear and when you
start understanding some of these
statistics like what's everybody afraid
of a bear market a bear market is when
you know market cracks 20% or more over
the last 80 years they've happened about
every three to five years to give you an
idea later years more five years well
now we've gone the longest period in
history without one and yet people are
still afraid after every single bear
market we've had in the history of the
United States that's led immediately
into a bull market if you remember
2008-2009 50% drop in the next 12 months
it was up Speers up 69 percent so almost
70 percent I can show you every turn
down so when you start seeing that it's
it's immutable it's like winter comes
but winter isn't forever and winter is a
great time to take advantage because
some people freeze to death in winter
other people ski and snowboard and get
by the fire well a winter is when things
are on sale if somebody said to you I
got a four thousand dollar Ferrari that
you could buy
$70,000 he probably grabbing a heartbeat
but if somebody takes you a stock that
was $40 at 70 bucks she's like oh my god
I can't do this you have to look at the
cycles of history when you do it you
become unshakable more importantly you
become wealthy so you talked about Kevin
Blanchard and and selling the business
and having money and investing it back
into the stock market what would you
tell the startup entrepreneur who maybe
is just getting started maybe he still
has a full-time job and it feels like
every dollar that they're making they're
just trying to build their business at
the moment they haven't cashed out yet
should they be invested into the
business should they still be saving
some went to the market what would you
tell that person I think you have to put
something outside your business because
what's the number one rule of investing
that even idiots understand
don't pull all your eggs in one basket
right and what a 90 percent of
entrepreneurs do because of the illusion
of control they go I'm gonna put all my
money in my business don't get me wrong
it's still a great place for your money
after your time with your energy but you
got to take a piece of what you earn and
you gotta bet on some other
entrepreneurs to get outside yourself
specifically and if you look at you know
somebody like Warren Buffett I'll tell
you you know what he said my all my
wealth as a result of a couple things
some good genes and compound interest
and living in America so if all you do
is get compound interest on your side
the game changes you don't have to a lot
of money what Kim Ledyard told me to do
that wasn't when I sold a business I was
in the business it was requiring so much
cash from me he was saying no matter how
much cash you got the business will
demand it you gotta take this percentage
and set it aside
and not give it to the business all
right you know I had a situation at one
point where I went through a divorce I'd
I initiated it but it was a brutal
divorce quite frankly and when I married
this woman she had no money and I lived
in her castle when I got divorce you
gotta eight times multiple on my
businesses and I had a pair a million
dollars a year for 18 years I married to
her for 14 years plus 42 million dollars
so I can tell you beyond a shadow of a
doubt that I woke up every day before I
could feed my own family how to pay this
woman a million bucks and I had to pay
the taxes on it
and the only way you can do that is
automate it and forget about it and add
value put focus on how to add value and
your business so I took it as a tax off
the top I never looked it again and I
just automated it and I gotta be honest
the first six to twelve months
you little crazy because I'm working my
guts out and she's not but what happened
was after a while it's just my skill
increased and what I found is anybody's
done this a business even the very
beginning and saying look if the
governor came in right now you put a 15%
additional tax on your business you'd
scream you yell you'd say I can't pay it
and you deffenbaugh but the difference
is the compounding here's what's
different I try to explain compounding
but you know think about like you want
to tell a kid this you know if you take
a 19 year old kid it's got a little job
and you say look I want you it sounds
like a lot but I want to put aside 300
hours a month let me show you why 380
bucks a month set aside throw it in the
market average market returns been 8%
spend 10% of a hundred years but most
recent you know thirty years eight
percent so let's say you get the average
return then it compounds that kid he
starts at nineteen where three hundred a
month can stop at 27 he's only done it
for eight years
never put another dime in and he's only
put in twenty four twenty eight thousand
dollars but that'll grow to 1.8 million
without putting him in a diamond that's
the power of compounding 28 grand 1.8
million if his best friend starts at 27
when he quits and the best every single
year all the way to 65 and he puts in
the same 300 ollars a month he puts in a
hundred forty grand and in that time
he's got four hundred thousand dollars
less money so it's not the amount of
money it's the amount of time time is
your greatest friend here and if you get
in the game you're gonna win and you
need to get the game now not wait to
your business to success how do you
decide what percentage you want to
allocate to investing it's great
question um if you look at what you want
to have in the end you know you hear
very often financial advisors today
still use this crazy number there we go
well you need like if you make $100,000
you need million bucks and that's the
biggest lie on the planet that was for
the days when you might be able to get a
10 percent return I don't know what days
you could do that totally secure maybe
back when interest rates are 18 percent
but there's no way that you're gonna get
a secure environment the whole idea is
to build your money up build your assets
up and eventually have the income
take care of you for the rest of your
life the only reason you invest is for
income income will buy you your trips
it'll put your kids through college
they'll pay for your home and give you
food people think they want
says assets can go up and down for any
period of time so you want to put in a
secure place at some plate where the
income provides all you need for the
rest of your life
well pretty hard to do that if you're
putting down an environment we're trying
to get 10% not gonna happen so you
really need 20 times your income that's
really the number that most people
should be utilizing some sounds very
compelling but when you understand
compounding like you know 300 ollars a
month for eight years turns into 1.8
million every put another diamond you
start to go hmm maybe I can still win
this game we don't think geometrically
we think you know step at a time and the
way stocks work or the way any of this
that works there's compounding in the
compounding is the greatest gift that we
have so so I guess it depends on your
age for how much answer your question I
would do as much as you could but I
would say as 10% would be the minimum
and you ideally want to build the 15 or
20 and they did a study four people said
they had no ability to invest they had
no money whatsoever and it was done by
this group of professors that were
eventually nominated for a Nobel Prize
and what they found was if they put a
lips cup and put aside 3% and anyone can
do 3% and then with every additional
increase in salary they put another 3%
aside within 15 years the average person
was saving 15% sixty-five percent we're
saving 19 percent these are workers in
middle class America making thirty five
thousand dollars a year to give you an
idea and at 19 or 20 percent you become
wealthy enough to screw up to not make
it at that point but if you think about
it today most people are gonna retire
based on actuarial statistics for no
less than 20 years some of them 30 or 35
years well they only work for 40 years
most people did not set aside the money
to make that happen so that's why I
wrote this book I want to do something
so simple you can read in a weekend and
saying okay here's what I'm being
screwed and I'm gonna save all that
money alone that just the savings you
can make on not overpaying and sees
every 1% and fees you pay more than you
should is 10 years of income you give up
in retirement because of compounding we
know that compounding works on
appreciation but compounding also works
on fees so you got to understand that
and I'm Jacob I walk you through it
because you cannot believe the abuse is
the
you talk a lot about the house and how
you're betting against a house and a
house always makes money so if
somebody's now listening to you and they
say okay great ten fifteen percent
twenty maybe I'm gonna I'm gonna save
what's my next step
I don't get the stock market I don't
know what to do next I'm not gonna give
it to a mutual fund like what's my next
step well I'm glad you said you want to
get you up to a mutual fund because most
people don't know that 98% of all mutual
funds in any ten year period you not
even match the market so if you're gonna
buy it something in that area you gotta
start out simple you want to buy the
index because it's so cheap but we're
you gotta think about where the most
people put their money they put it in a
401k that's where 90% of Americans have
the largest sum of money it's their home
in their form okay in the form of K is
bigger and the problem is you keep like
you said people know where to go so when
I tell people first step make the most
important and death financial decision
you like you're gonna pay yourself first
there's gonna be some money you're gonna
keep forever for you and your family not
giving the capes paid or to Amazon or
anybody else
here's that percentage and to automate
it so you don't see it second step is
now we got this bucket of money we're
building up where the hell do I put it
and in that case the most important
financial decision investment decision I
should say is the decision of asset
allocation which is a big word for how
much money do you put in low-risk
environments where you probably get
smaller returns but less risk how much
do you put in higher risk environments
like the stock market or real estate
where you have unlimited upside which
all seven limited downside as well and
so how do you balance that out and the
answer is the question we walk you
through in the book how to make those
decisions but here are some of the
criteria you're an angel you said is
number one because how much time do you
need before you need this money is huge
if I'm you know in a position let's say
I got two buckets a secure bucket low
risk you know low returns a risk growth
bucket more risk more growth or more
loss what percentage do I put like 60
percent secure forty percent here do I
do
20 percent secure 80 percent at risk and
that has to do with number one how much
time do you need so if you need the
money in five years you can't afford to
take chat risk because if you screw up
you got no room if you're 20 years old
how you can screw up many times and
still make the win the game so that's
number one number two is what's your
risk tolerance and in the book we have
some tests for you
because what people think there is
tolerance is and what it really is are
two different things
we play a game or one of my seminars
where I say I put some music on and say
make change with people around you they
gonna go make change they reach other
pockets and start making change and the
ends after one song for five minutes and
I go on to the next subject and
inevitably somebody Santa goes I want my
money back this effort over here took a
hundred bucks and gave me five bucks
because and I go first of all what makes
you think it's your money I said second
of all let me to think the game is over
you know and if somebody stressed about
a hundred bucks and you're gonna be an
investor you're gonna be in trouble so
you got to know your risk tolerance in
the last what your access to cash flow
you have a lot of extra access cash flow
you've got room to take more risks if
you don't have much cash flow you're
gonna have to be more selective and and
what you're gonna put at risk how
important is the education side in that
should I just be putting my money to the
index and I don't don't worry about it
it's gonna go up seven ten percent a
year and pay super low fees versus I
need to understand the actual stocks to
buy if Amazon's a good buy or not like
how much do you advise understanding the
individual companies or should it just
be kind of set it forget it by the index
looking at once a year then don't worry
about it I don't think you want to just
do the index because you want to have
different asset classes if you look at
the best investors in the world they all
understand that they're gonna be wrong
you talked to Ray Dalio the greatest
hedge fund investor in the history of
the world guy made a fortune in 2008
when everyone else is losing money and
what does he tell you he says Tony you
have to have money in each different
asset class because different
environments the environments will
change no matter how smart people think
they are they're gonna be wrong and you
got to structure yourself so you're able
to make money no matter what so you
don't want just you know the index but
what you do want to do is you do not
want to be probably someone who's trying
to evaluate individual stocks that's
really you know somebody's gonna try to
be a trader and in most cases that's not
gonna work now if you're Warren Buffett
that's a different piece but maybe
better to invest with Warren Buffett is
better at selection than you are
then you trying to do it stock picking
nobody wins at it the best in the world
but when you got people that are
supposed to be the best hedge fund guys
on earth and what's their track record
over the last seven years it's pathetic
they've not even matched the market
right and so that's why you've seen this
shake-up in the hedge fund industry
because after you paid for fees even
with their brilliant minds you end up
lower than if you just own the market
itself so the answer to question is
you need to diversify let me give you
the four things if I may yeah the four
most important things that I found there
were only things in common
I interviewed 50 of the smartest
financial people who world but they all
have different approaches you know you
look at Warren Buffett he has a very
different approach then say Ray Dalio
does right ones a you know looking at
trends in the market the others looking
at individual companies and trying to
take advantage of the best possible
evaluations as you possibly can so but
here's what they all agree on number one
and I know this sounds basic they're
obsessed with not losing money most
investors obsessed with trying to make
money but because they know that if I
lose a hundred thousand dollars you know
and I want to grow it back I can't just
go and grow it a little small rate to
make that happen let's say I lose 50% of
it I have $50,000 how much do I got to
grow to get even most people say well
you lost 50 percent you got to grow 30%
they don't realize if you have $100,000
is only worth 50 now you got to grow a
hundred percent to get even so the
smartest investors know they're gonna be
wrong and they have an asset allocation
they broken up their assets in a way but
even if they're wrong it's not gonna
hurt them sooner second this is the one
that's more interesting they all are
obsessed with this idea of how do I have
the least amount of risk with the most
amount of return they call an
asymmetrical risk return risk reward and
what they look at is when I started
working with Paul Tudor Jones one of the
10 best investors in history he had lost
money first sometime he had been the
most successful industry in the you know
the meltdown that happened you know this
largest stock market is in the history
meltdown that we had he lost 20% in a
day he made 200 percent that year first
his skies and made I think it remember I
forty percent that month I mean this is
a brilliant brilliant guy but here's how
he doesn't he doesn't invest like most
investors he doesn't say like we're can
I get a nice return he's looking for a
five to one where if he risks a dollar
he believes I made fives now he's gonna
be wrong he knows he's gonna be wrong so
if I risk a dollar try make five and I'm
wrong okay I can risk another dog he can
risk four out of five dollars and still
make money right so it that puts you in
a very different position than most
people you know if you look at somebody
like Richard Branson's a friend and
Richard is just the genius as you know
but when most people don't have a clue
like when he started Virgin Airlines he
only started with five airplanes
my investments right these boeing
business jets but what people don't know
is he spent a year negotiating so you
had no downside if he didn't succeed in
the first three years he negotiated a
deal to give back the planes with no
credit loss nothing lost to him so it
was all upside no downside that's called
asymmetrical risk reward um Kyle Bass is
a friend of mine he is well known during
the 2008 crisis because he took 20
million dollars and turned into four
billion in the worst economic
environment we've had in 80 years and
how'd he do it but I could explain the
details but he bet against real estate
when everybody else is betting on it he
looked at the facts but here's the
secret
every time he invested six cents in
order and that's risk success his upside
was a dollar so if you risk success you
can be wrong 15 times and still make
money well he wasn't wrong 15 times thus
he made 2 billion out of 20 million in 3
and a half years so asymmetrical risk
reward is what they're looking for you
can't always get a 5 to 1 a 3 to 1 but
you want to be looking for it you want
to think differently than the average
person third they're all completely
obsessed with tax efficiency but not
until they first have done the first two
if you just try to do something based on
taxes it's not the right investment but
if it's something where you can feel
relatively certain you won't lose money
and you've set up an asset allocation if
you're wrong you're still okay and then
you've got tremendous risk reward small
risk big reward then you want to make
sure it's tax efficient cos I'd trade
all the people who work for me don't
tell me the return tell me the net
return tell me after taxes after fees
after everything because it's very
different than what people do and so you
know if you take a dollar and you know
you know compounding me you double it 20
times it's a million in 48 thousand but
if you just paid thirty three percent in
tax which is less than most of what your
viewers probably are it should say more
than what less than probably what most
your viewers or listeners probably pay
most probably more on the fifty percent
tax range if you think about it at 33
percent taken out after 20 turns you
think well how much is that it was a
million 48 you take out thirty three
percent well that's only three hundred
thirty thousand roughly yeah you're on
three at that no no that math doesn't
work this is compounding instead of a
million forty-eight thousand if you paid
thirty three percent tax each year you
twenty-eight thousand dollars instead of
a million in 48 so tax efficiency baby
is huge and then the last one is when I
talk to you about from the beginning
which is every investor believes in
diversification across multiple elements
in other words you don't want to just
buy real estate you want different
assets or just the index like you
described that's a disaster because
there'll be times when the index will
get hit and you need something to
balance it out you're only in one place
you're gonna get hurt and the pain will
be so strong you're probably selling
than have a permanent wound or a
permanent problem you don't want that to
happen so you need diversity across
different assets you don't want just one
giant piece of real estate you want
diversity with an asset classes so
multiple pieces of real estate or or
owning the index is the example you want
diversification across different
economies and you want diversification
across time which is what dollar cost
averaging can do so those are four
things that the greatest investors on
earth all do in common even though they
have different approaches to making
money I love it I love it Wow got to
rewind that a couple times to really let
it digest I know we're bumping up
against the clock Tony guys who are
watching live replay the book is linked
up in the description below UPW if you
want to see me as well in New York and
November's linked up below
Tony the third link that we have in the
description is about your feed America
campaign trying to feed a hundred
million families do you want to just
quickly talk about that for my honey
actually fed 100 million every year for
four straight years this year will hit
400 million I committed to feed a
billion meals over the next 10 years so
over six years out from the billion but
I'm really pleased with it but every
book the book has just come out in
paperback so everybody knows so please
pick it up and if you do pick it up 50
meals get paper I donate a hundred
percent of this book's revenues
everything to feeding America so and if
you want to join me and go to feeding
America every dollar you donate i will
duplicate meaning if you put in a
hundred dollars i'll put it on it if you
put in a million i'll put in a million
up to four million each year to give you
an idea so love it if you take advantage
of this change your own life with
unshakable you can read in the weekend
but you'll also be helping those that
are in need right now we're the richest
country in the world we got 49 million
people don't know where their next meal
is gonna come from seventeen million or
children I was one of them so it's not a
snap to me and that's why I'm doing this
so hope people will pick up the book
I'll go up and touch their lives
also they can change other lives while
they're doing it I love it well we've
linked all three of those things guys up
in the description below Tony you've got
a minute a half left final message my
audience I would just say look if you're
a you have a lot of entrepreneurs in
your audience and I have 54 companies
myself we do about six billion in
business a little more than that now and
I can tell you had no background what in
business what made me is effective was
that I wouldn't get involved in a
business just to make money I'm in the
ball for the business because it's a
mission it's something that I think can
change somebody's life and whether it's
something as simple as stem cell
business or whether it's LAF see a
soccer team I own or whether it's a
resort in Fiji
I try to do something that's gonna
change their lives and the whole focus
and business is add more value there is
no other rule if you do more for others
than anybody else does in the
marketplace you'll build a brand people
get on their knees and reach behind a
soda pop to get a coca-cola
even though coke doesn't win most the
taste test it is the brand you will
become the brand if you can do more for
others than anybody else does and I hope
that your audience the reason they're
listening to you is to figure out how to
add more and more value to the
marketplace and the last thing I'll say
to them since they're entrepreneurs is
find who your ideal customer is and
build your business around that the
customer that's going to do the most
with you the customer is going to refer
the most the customer that when winter
does come will still buy from you
find out who that is and over service
them and you'll have no difficulty
growing your business Tony Robbins
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
man I'll see you in November and I
really appreciate you taking the time
today thanks for having me on take care
bro